i'm curious when we last spoke you told
me that you didn't originally get this
role and that you got cast after they
came back around and you had come back
in
so once you were cast as this character
where did you start how did you approach
building him did you start with the
script did you start with the books did
you start with the physical side of it
was it a combination of things
yeah well i had yeah i had i had seen
some of the scripts so um i had an
understanding of kind of the tone of the
show but it was all about the books for
me i mean i you know as an actor um my
first the first step that i take is to
absorb as much material as i can that
exists right whether that's just the
script or a script and a pitch deck that
the the writers have or in this case i
had 24 books to pour over
so my you know my job was reading these
books and it didn't feel like work at
all i mean i love i love the books
and uh quickly became as big a fan as
anybody um so you know when i have so
much material and i've seen reacher in
so many situations it really answers
kind of all the questions i could have
about how he would treat a certain
person or situation you know so um it
was uh you know it gave me a firm
footing to get started with um and then
the scripts were incredible as well nick
santor our showrunner um did an amazing
job adapting the book faithfully but but
also you know creating really
three-dimensional character in reacher
and those uh supporting characters like
will fitzgerald oscar
sorry oscar finley played by malcolm
goodwin i mean just amazing talent um
for roscoe and finley and that trifecta
um you know i think he really brought
them to life in a way that um i think
even
betters it's it sort of bests the the
books
in a way
obviously with the season following one
book you didn't have to read 24 books so
why did the character become so
important to you i mean you've you've
been in this business a lot you you've
played quite a few standout rules so
what was it that set this apart and made
him
so special for you that you went above
and beyond in a way that you didn't
necessarily have to
well i just fell in love with who this
character is like
you know hundreds of millions of people
have read these books and i i don't i
don't think it's by accident that so
many people have taken a liking to who
this is he provides a level of wish
fulfillment in us you know just
as a citizen myself i i crave a
mysterious stranger sweeping into town
and taking care of the things that our
justice system is too slow or cumbersome
to take care of um
but also he's um a complex character in
that he's incredibly intelligent he's
very physical he's got a propensity to
violence um but he's also really funny
and trying to combine that dry sense of
humor with that that that that wit or
that mystery about him is a complicated
thing to bring to life and i was you
know i'm i like the challenge i mean i i
don't want to be bored in playing a
character and um uh i see all those
dimensions and i i want to take it on
you know and i want to honor who he is
for all the fans
when you take on something like this at
what point do you stop thinking about
all of the fans of the book series about
what tom cruise did before you and you
figure out
how you want to make the character your
own did you have a moment when it really
sort of all clicked for you and it felt
like that all lined up
yeah i don't know if i'll ever stop
thinking about the fans and because i'm
one of them you know i mean there's a
pressure that i feel too to go like i i
really want to get this right i care so
much about this character and this
franchise um uh just in a very personal
way uh but you know it it the the
pressure kind of eased a little bit
there was a
a huge presence of producers and
executives and and writers and we had
amazing directors and everybody
has access to the books that i have too
right so i mean they all have an opinion
on who reacher is to them
and um it was a truly collaborative
effort in a way that i i haven't
experienced before i mean i've played
kind of iconic characters before that
have a lot of ip attached to it but um
you know i mean you know i'd have
long sit down meetings or i'd receive
long letters from people go like this is
who i see for this first episode or
second episode
and it's like okay i'm just taking all
of it in and let's play around let's
tinker let's try him this way let's try
him your way you know everybody saw
something a little different
and uh and i think it was just about
being open and availing myself to what
what i thought what the directors or
producers thought and i think where we
ended up was the most authentic place
because we all pitched in you know
there's a lot on your shoulders for this
show
you're playing the tyler character of a
popular book series you're in pretty
much every scene you have a ton of
physical work and stunts and action
going on
and all of it is happening for an entire
season and possibly multiple seasons not
just at the length of a movie so is it
sometimes a relief that this is a guy
who doesn't always have a lot to say
oh sure yeah you know and i i you know
reacher said nothing is a very famous
uh
turn of phrase in the books and uh you
know as an actor
you don't wish for no lines but you go
you go like okay maybe this is one where
i you know it's not going to be paige's
dialogue and then of course it's a
little difficult to adapt reacher said
nothing to screen so he does he does he
does talk a lot we get to hear his
thought process out loud and it's a lot
of fun
um
you know to see the way that he breaks
down the characters around him or the
world that he's in um
uh but uh yeah there's you know it was
uh
a false positive for me because i came
in and you know it's just pages of uh of
him unraveling somebody um so i don't
get to sit back and relax like i maybe
had hope but uh but yeah i think um it's
regardless i think it's a lot of fun for
people and i'd be happy to to play this
guy for every every book i mean we let's
see if we can bring them all to life
you say in this show tall people never
have enough room for their feet and as a
six foot tall woman i'd like to thank
you for speaking that truth
yes was it was it fun to incorporate
some of the obvious issues that come up
and some of the natural humor that
arises from being so tall i mean was all
of that always in the script or was some
of that added along the way yeah i think
a lot of it was in the script um you
know
there's an awareness that he has that
the world perceives large people in a
certain way and a lot of that he uses to
his advantage you know i experience in
my own life you know i'm not small and
um you know people sort of assume that
i'm either an [ __ ] or a brutishly
dumb and um i
would like to think that i'm not either
you know um and and uh you know i think
reacher uses that to his advantage um
but yes i mean there there's an
awareness and being able to talk about
what the world is like for large people
when a lot of people don't deal with
those kinds of challenges or
difficulties or or stereotypes you know
um was fun but you know i think nick
santora our our rider showrunner
did a really incredible job capturing
who this guy is uh and adapting what lee
set up on the page um so i you know a
lot of that i i give credit to uh
santora and the writers
i love the odd buddy duo dynamic going
on between rachel and finlay it's it's
such a fun relationship because those
two characters couldn't be more
different
right you what did you enjoy about that
dynamic and what did malcolm goodwin
bring to that relationship
malcolm goodwin is uh one of the finest
actors i've worked with he brought a lot
to the character i mean he uh he made
those scenes very fun and i felt
you know even even within a scene
working with him i would think to myself
this is so fun to be able to watch him
work this close you know um but you know
you've got kind of this odd couple
there's something very nostalgic about
it almost like that kind of 80s odd
couple that we've seen in some features
you know and uh there's a lot of tension
and conflict at first and and uh their
relationship develops over the course of
the season and becomes rather touching
and heartfelt at moments it was a lot of
fun to work with him on that um and i
think um
you know a lot of times it takes a few
episodes to find to hit a stride with
another actor that you haven't worked
with before and
both with
malcolm and willa fitzgerald who plays
roscoe it was immediate i mean the
chemistry i think was there
in a very immediate rare way um it
didn't take us any time at all but by
the time we were finished shooting the
first episode it felt like we've been
um
we've been working together for for
years you know so it's i think that's a
credit to who they are as performers and
um it was a it was a real gift to work
with them
it also feels like it it would take a
very particular kind of woman to crack
through to the emotions of someone like
jack reacher
so what is it about roscoe that he
connects with and
how was it to explore that relationship
right yeah well i think um i i think you
i think you hit the nail on the head you
know
roscoe is some somebody with this
unwavering strength and
really that comes from willa i mean she
is so powerful and i i said before she
you know she has this way uh about her
um that she can really pierce
the windows to your soul i mean i've
never worked with somebody who can look
through you the way that she does it's
just very she's very powerful and uh you
know roscoe is the beneficiary of that
um you know i think reacher sort of
relies on and um enjoys the fact that
his presence is so intimidating that it
puts most people on their heels and then
you have this little firecracker in
roscoe who's not intimidated at all but
you know pushed around at all and uh i
think she represents really the the best
side of women i think women are
incredibly strong um i think they are to
be revered and uh the gift that women
bring to the world is something that we
really should hold in the highest esteem
and um and she represents all this the
best strengths of of women and um she's
a lot of fun to watch i think
women will enjoy the show as much as men
i think a lot a lot of the times you
know before getting into the franchise
this is framed as kind of for me at
least as kind of an actioner for for men
and i think it is that but it's also so
much more and i think women will enjoy
this as much as men people who have read
the books will enjoy this as much as
those who have not
yeah i mean i was really impressed that
this is a show with the really great
female character because it is one of
those things it seems like
might be challenging on a show like this
sure and again i mean this is really a
credit to nick santora i think
you know there's a three-dimensionality
to
the supporting cast as much as reacher i
think it would be very easy for a writer
to go um let's focus on reacher and you
know then there's the other characters
but you know really um it's the uh very
interesting orbit that these other
characters take and the the dimension
that we see in them that makes this show
work so well it's
it's not it's not as much reacher as it
is these fascinating other actors that
we get to work with you know so um uh
that i think that's what makes it so fun
and uh again that really goes back to
what's on the page i don't think that
it's it's hard to watch the show and
distinguish between what was in the
books and what wasn't um and i think
that's really that's a testament to just
an amazing team um
in all in a lot of different ways you
know so um it's
it's faithfully adapted but but
it almost bests the books and how these
supporting characters are set up and
portrayed
have you already started to have
conversations about a possible second
season i mean would you go in order and
do the second book for a second season
uh yeah i would go i would go for all i
think the winners are 26 now i think i
would do them all and uh you know if we
can wrap this up when i'm 74 75 i'd be
happy
um yeah sure i don't know
i don't know about a second season but
my fingers are crossed as hard as
anything
when you have such great characters like
finley and roscoe i mean
are you guys trying to find a way to
bring them back into the series i mean
how do you make it so that he doesn't
fully move on
yeah you know this is this would be
most likely a bit of an anthology right
i mean it's uh you know the first season
is the first book um that may be the
blueprint going forward i don't know but
um i would imagine that would be the
blueprint going forward and you know in
one respect um there's the part of you
that goes like well if we work with any
real diva actors the good thing is i
wouldn't have to see them again next
year the problem is
i really fell in love with everybody
that i worked with i mean every cast
member all the way down to day players
who are there just for one line were
some of the best uh
actors and actresses that i've ever
worked with and not only that there were
wonderful people too they're great to be
on set with
so it's rather tragic i think that um
there's a chance that i may not see some
of them again but um they set the bar so
high i i i think
we'd be remiss not to see them show up
again so i hope we do i don't know how
that'll play out um um but you know that
would be one area that we deviate from
the books a little bit um i think uh to
the benefit of audiences you know
if we see them pop up more i mean i just
loved everybody on the show even even
the you know what's supposed to be the
bad guys i just thought everybody
just already studied their characters so
well that i just i loved i can't and i
can't imagine anybody
anybody else playing any of the
characters
i feel the same way yeah
including the work that you do is jack
region it's definitely you know when you
take on a character like that it is such
large shoes to fill so
did you have a day on set was it
at a time when you were doing a
you know a fight scene or was it a quiet
moment that you really felt like him
oh sure well you know i think you know i
think as the season went on it started
to feel more and more like okay i think
we
are landing in the right spot and i'm
starting to feel very comfortable making
the choices that i'm making but it was a
group effort you know i mean there's
you know
even one degree different in tone you
know whether we
take it you know dial it up a click as
far as the drama or the you know the
mysterious or or or even like kind of a
malicious nature that we give him you
know if we do dial it up click to the
left or right it could make this show
feel very different
and so i'm down to the degree i think we
really worked as a team to find the
right balance between um you know that
dry sense of humor that is so
entertaining um and um you know the
seriousness at which he approaches um
his world of justice you know so um
it was a balancing act and we really
spent a lot of time playing with that
together as a team um but as the as the
season went on it started to feel more
comfortable and i think you know as the
producers started to leave because they
felt like we had it you know it started
to feel like okay i think
like we know who reacher is and i think
this is uh this adaptation is working
well thank you for the show
i just i loved all of it i was surprised
at how much i laughed and i just i
appreciate it thank you so much
thank you very much i'm glad you enjoyed
it